bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regardera vite vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la Journée mondiale de
la liberté de la presse bonsoir Pauline
Alès Nevel et merci d'être notre grand
témoin ce soir vous êtes la porte-parole
des RECF rssf qui publie aujourd'hui son
classement mondial pour 2023 180 pays
passés au crible et le moins que son
plus vite c'est que le tableau global
est plutôt très sombre pour l'exercice
du journalisme dans le monde on va y
revenir longuement vous mettez l'accent
cette année sur la technologie qui est
le principal véhicule de la
désinformation on y revient longuement
tout à l'heure mais on va commencer par
débattre ce soir des Black Blocs ces
groupes de militants radicaux qui
infiltrent les manifestations venu en
masse le 1er mai ils ont provoqué de
très violents affrontements avec les
forces de l'ordre alors pourquoi la
France n'arrive pas à les endiguer
faut-il une nouvelle loi anti-casseurs
pour y parvenir en débat avec mes
invités dans un instant sur ce plateau
avant de retrouver aux alentours de
20h15 les affranchis pour leur parti
pris et puis Bourbon Express ce soir
exit le rip la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel dire tout juste de
tomber voilà pour le menu vous me suivez
Pauline et bien c'est parti
[Musique]
existe-t-il une solution pour les
arrêter nom de code Black Bloc bloc noir
en anglais pour ces groupes violents qui
ont fait des générer les défilés du 1er
mai à Paris à Lyon notamment de plus en
plus nombreux dans les cortèges depuis
le 49-3 de plus en plus incontrôlable
aussi bonsoir Thomas rudygoz et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
député renaissance du Rhône il y a eu
beaucoup de casse à Lyon beaucoup de
saccages on va y revenir le 1er mai bien
sûr bonsoir Raquel Garrido bonsoir ravi
de vous accueillir vous êtes député la
France insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis
dans les cortèges aussi ce 1er mai
j'imagine bien évidemment bonsoir
Thierry Vincent vous aussi vous avez
suivi de près ce cortège du 1er mai vous
êtes journaliste d'investigation vous
publiez dans la tête des Black Blocs aux
éditions de l'Observatoire enfin bonsoir
Linda kebab bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes délégué national unité sgpfo
auteur de gardienne de la paix et de la
révolte chez Stock vous vous étiez aussi
dans les cortèges je le précise mais
comme manifestante une policière qui
manifeste contre la réforme des
retraites je crois que vous avez quand
même bien regardé ce qui s'était passé à
la fin place de la Nation Pauline Alès
Mevel n'hésitez pas à intervenir je sais
que vous regardez de près aussi à RSF la
manière dont les journalistes sont
traités dans les cortèges on parlera
sûrement de ce qui s'est passé pour Rémi
beuzine de brut on va commencer par
planter le décor comme chaque soir que
s'est-il passé alors très précisément ce
premier mai il a deux secondes deux
secondes pas une de plus c'est le chrono
de Blacko pour démarrer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir mon
cher Stéphane oups j'en perds mes
feuilles j'entendais des choses tombées
je me dis qu'est-ce que j'ai perdu de
rien grave bonsoir à vous tous et toutes
alors pour parler de la violence dans
les manifs mais avant rappelons malgré
tout même si on le fait à chaque fois
que l'immense majorité des manifestants
étaient totalement Pacifique peut
montrer bien sûr quelques images des
cordes à officiel orange les CFDT rouge
la CGT mais ça a été complètement
éclipsé par la violence en dehors des
cortèges officiels donc d'abord les
chiffres le ministère de l'Intérieur
nous dit qu'il y a eu 400 polices
sublesses dans toute la France 300 rien
qu'à Paris et puis des images choquantes
notamment celle que vous avez sans doute
déjà vu de ce policier qui a été atteint
par un cocktail Molotov qui a été
gravement brûlé au visage alors qui sont
les responsables on met en cause les
fameux Black Blocs on commence un peu à
connaître on sait que sont les
activistes habillées en noir pour pas
qu'on les identifie selon leurs
vêtements très organisés pour casser et
échapper à la police mais en fait c'est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué que ça
parce que il se positionne en avant du
cortège où ils ne sont pas seuls il y a
là aussi d'autres manifestants qui
déambulent en dehors des cortèges
syndicaux et donc tout le monde se
mélange un peu et c'est de là que tout
démarre nous explique le préfet de
police on appelle ça le pré cortège
c'est au sein de ce précortel que
généralement se constitue de Black Blocs
qui sont en fait animés par des éléments
radicaux qui appartiennent très souvent
tout le temps même en ce moment à
l'ultra gauche il se moque éperdument
des causes de ces manifestations
puisqu'on les a vu dans tous les
cortèges ils étaient présents pour les
gilets jaunes ils étaient présents
contre la loi el khomri en 2016 et ils
sont présents aujourd'hui leur but c'est
de mettre à mal notre démocratie
représentative
vous avez entendu le préfet de police à
lâché le mot la violence dans les manifs
ça vient de l'ultra gauche d'ailleurs il
a précisé qu'il avait 2200 activistes de
l'ultra gauche qui étaient fichés donc
considéré par la police comme une menace
pour la sécurité de l'État donc la
police les a identifié mais on les
arrête que si on les prend en flagrant
délit ce qui n'est pas évident en
attendant dans
ultra gauche y a gauche donc forcément
c'est un peu tentant pour le
gouvernement de donner une part de
responsabilité à la gauche au-delà de
l'ultra gauche d'ailleurs quand il
s'agit de mettre en cause Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans le pourrissement des
manifs à part la violence Gérald
Darmanin n'y va pas avec le dos de la
cuillère en l'écoute
Monsieur Mélenchon lui tout était bon
pour faire la démagogie pour exciter
juste avant la manifestation une partie
de la population il a une partie de
responsabilité en tout cas on peut se
poser la question lorsque l'on voit
quelques heures avant les manifestations
Monsieur Mélenchon dire de tels mots
contre le président de la République de
tel mot contre les forces de l'ordre
c'est lui qui dit la police tue la
police tue la police tue alors
évidemment pas question pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous doutez bien de se plier
aux injonctions de Gérald Darmanin donc
il a contraqué contre-attaqué avec un
argument assez imparable qui consiste à
dire c'est celui qui dit qui est et oui
c'est de la haute dialectique mais en
définitive ça revient à dire ça vous
voyez puisque lui dit en fait non c'est
Darmanin qui est 100% responsable de ces
violences en attendant bon quand même
les insoumis sont un petit peu dans les
cordes et à défaut de condamner les
violences contre les policiers et bien
manuel Bompard veut bien les déplorer on
l'écoute mon parti est comme vous le
dites mouvement la France insoumise et
l'ensemble de ces dirigeants on touche
de redis qu'ils étaient bien évidemment
opposés à toute forme de violence contre
qui que ce et donc quand il y a des
images inacceptables comme celles que
vous êtes en train de de montrer bien
évidemment on les on les on les déplore
bref donc ce débat par un peu stérile
puisque ça consiste à se s'accuser
mutuellement à se rejeter la faute l'un
sur l'autre alors avant de vous laisser
les bats je vais laisser la parole à
quelqu'un d'autre c'est Philippe Astruc
c'est le procureur de Rennes donc ce
lundi à Rennes j'ai des chiffres avec
moi 350 personnes ont été interpellées
pendant les manifs 162 ont été placés en
garde à vue et sur 162-108 sont
poursuivis par la justice et bien
pourtant selon ce procureur parmi ces
personnes poursuivies donc a priori
prise en flagrant délit aucun n'avait le
profil de quelqu'un qui était coutumier
de la violence on l'écoute c'est des
gens qui ont très peu ou pas
d'antécédents judiciaire voilà c'est
c'est pas des gens aguerris des qui ont
déjà de long casier c'est pas euh les
jeunes délinquants comment on pourrait
le penser pas du tout il y a aussi
évidemment des phénomènes
d'entraînement mais le profil est assez
sont plutôt des gens qui ou qui sont en
formation des jeunes oui mais pas que
pas que donc je vais pas calculer la
moyenne d'âge mais je dirais c'est
monsieur et madame tout le monde
alors je vais vous laisser des batteries
mais je me demande si le plus inquiétant
c'est pas cette conclusion c'est l'idée
que maintenant des gens tout à fait
ordinaires comme dit le procureur pense
que à part la violence il y a aucun
moyen de se faire entendre en France et
ça c'est un embêtant quand même merci
merci pour ce pour ce billet Stéphane
lakowski avant d'aller voir les
politiques j'aimerais bien les
observateurs puisque vous y étiez
Thierry Vincent qu'est-ce que vous avez
vu dans ce cortège parisien du 1er mai
est-ce que vous avez vu des Black Blocs
justement en masse ou des gens comme
vous et moi c'était impossible de pas
les voir effectivement ça a été très
violent dès le début de la manif hein
vous savez même pas démarrer que déjà il
y avait des affrontements bon il y a des
des agences bancaires dégradées etc ça
c'est relativement classique mais le
c'est surtout le le nombre qui était
très impressionnant alors Gérald
Darmanin dit le nombre de Black Blocs il
dit 2000 ça doit être à peu près ça mais
surtout le je pense que le chiffre le
plus important c'est la conclusion de
votre votre chroniqueur c'est que il y a
20000 personnes dans le pré cortège ou
cortège de tête comme disait
manifestants les 20 000 personnes qui
sont reportages de tête c'est énorme
parce que déjà rien que 20 000 isolément
c'est une grosse manif déjà Paris et
quand vous avez 20 000 personnes quand
vous placez dans le cortège de tête vous
manifestez quand même un certain si ce
n'est soutien en tout cas du genre sous
compréhension
vis-à-vis des gens qui se livrent à des
actions
uniquement des gens non parce que des
militants radicaux si vous défilez hors
syndicat c'est c'est et en plus qui de
fait ça complique l'intervention de la
police parce que c'est là où
effectivement c'est compliqué on dit
toujours pourquoi on n'arrête pas les
villages block bah si c'était facile je
pense que la police arrêterait mais
alors qui sont-ils vous avez enquêté
vous les connaissez qu'est-ce que c'est
le bloc c'est quoi c'est qui je connais
modestement
c'est difficile d'établir un profil mais
ce qu'on peut dire alors moi je
distingue deux choses distingue Black
Bloc vraiment historique militant et là
ce qu'on voit parce que je pense que les
les méthodes radicales de manifestation
illégale je pense des bords de largement
du cadre maintenant du cadre
traditionnel Black Bloc historique c'est
très jeune
au-dessus de 30 ans il n'a pas beaucoup
bon pour des raisons assez évidentes de
physiquement tout ça puis bon moralement
enfin faut être prêt à
aller en garde à vue à être condamné
parce qu'il y a quand même des
condamnations
on les laisse faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est pas vrai la justice quand elle les
attrape et n'est pas spécialement
clémente c'est moins convivial armée
casquette armée casquette comment on
comment ça se passe précisément
poursuivez sur le profil pardonnez-moi
c'est intéressant de vous entendre sur
le profil terminé alors bon Gérald
Darmanin dit lac Bourges à mon avis
c'est vraiment une caricature bon bah
Darmanin fait du Darmanin mais ce qui
est vrai en revanche c'est que c'est
plutôt des gens à capital culturel élevé
sur typiquement étudiant lycéen même
parce qu'elle est très très jeune il y
en a qui ont 15 ans vraiment là il y en
avait le 1er mai comme les manies avant
assez féminin ça se féminise pas à peu
près un tiers à la fois selon la police
et selon d'ailleurs les les militants
radicaux
quand on se dit du bloc qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est un militantisme politique
anti capitaliste pour moi ou c'est pour
moi
et dure je pense qu'il y a aussi
frissons de de oui de l'adrénaline et
tout ça évidemment ça rentre en ligne de
compte et ça c'est sûr mais en faire
simplement des des des pures vandales ou
du ou des puruliganes on comprend pas
grand chose une fois qu'on a dit ça
parce que bon ils sont délinquants dans
le sens où oui ils commettent des délits
donc quelqu'un en droit quelqu'un qui
commet un délit les délinquants comme
certains hommes politiques qui ont
commis des lits sont délinquants aussi
mais mais ce ne sont pas des délinquants
d'habitude ce ne sont pas c'est ce
qu'elles disent d'ailleurs le procureur
de Rennes je crois qu'il disait
maintenant c'est monsieur madame tout le
monde c'est pas c'est pas des gens qui
ont des casiers hors des lits en
manifestation très souvent c'est des
gens plutôt inséré socialement là je
parle la box vraiment d'origine
effectivement milieu culturel plutôt
élevé par
intermittents du spectacle genre de
profession journaliste parfois aussi ça
arrive la réforme des retraites c'est
leur sujet en deux mots pour sujet c'est
pour terminer je fais circuler
le capitalisme donc là c'est une mesure
libérale qui va vers pour eux donc oui
ils sont contre mais c'est plus large la
lutte elle est il y avait 5000 policiers
dans la capitale et on a vu ces images
c'est violent et même plus bien plus
violents qu'avant le fait qu'il soit au
début du cortège ça ça change beaucoup
de choses ou pas oui ça change puisque
autrefois ils étaient tout à l'arrière
bien enfin bien éloigné des cortèges
officiels déclarés de l'intersyndicale
ou autre et donc du coup ce format
voiture balai permettait de faciliter un
petit peu l'action des forces de l'ordre
qui mettait un cordon entre les derniers
manifestants et le bloc et donc du coup
on pouvait exercer plus facilement alors
on rencontre là aujourd'hui c'est eux
qui donnent le tempo du cortège alors
que quand vous êtes un manifestant au
sein du cortège officiel et ben
régulièrement vous subissez des arrêts
et j'ai fait toutes les mobilisations
régulièrement vous vous arrêtez et quand
on le sait on apprend très rapidement
c'est parce qu'il y a des violences en
amont et donc du coup tout l'ensemble
des dizaines centaines de milliers de
manifestants doivent s'arrêter donc oui
ça change tout et ça complique le
travail parce que beaucoup de
manifestants aussi du coup on peut le
comprendre sont curieux de savoir ce qui
se passe devant donc eux continuent et
se retrouve au milieu de ce bloc curieux
seulement oui quand il y a des sommets
en général il y a des avertissements et
on demande aux manifestants de quitter
le cortège s'il y a des difficultés
il y a quelque chose de très particulier
comme il le disait c'est que dans
l'ensemble de ce bloc il y a pas que du
Black Bloc il y a des soutiens à ces
gens-là il y a des personnes qui
viennent aussi insulter tout le long du
cortège des policiers mais jusqu'à lors
les CRS les gendarmes mobiles ou les
compagnies interventions sont habitués à
être insultés donc du coup ils ont une
résilience vis-à-vis de ça ils
interviennent en fait dès lors qu'il y a
des violences et notamment quand elles
sont jugées non plus plus supportables
je rappelle une chose c'est que le
maintien de l'ordre à la française
traditionnellement c'est une acceptation
du certain désordre donc être insulté
j'ai envie de dire pour les policiers ou
un petit peu bousculé dans l'absolu
c'est quelque chose qui est accepté donc
du coup il y a aussi ce type de profil
il y a eu un petit peu je veux pas
vulgariser mais gilet jaune les gens qui
sont juste en colère mais pareil qui ne
lancent pas des cocktails Molotov et
puis vous avez ces personnes qui très
vite sans capuche se masque et puis
lance des cocktail Molotov des bombes
agricoles et tape tout doux signe leur
méfaits avec le a entouré anarchie donc
voilà donc du coup c'est quand même
signé donc quand j'entends le préfet de
police et je suis vous savez que je suis
pas toujours tendre avec les autorités
qui qui signent qui dit que l'ultra
gauche signe ses gestes oui c'est
factuel moi j'ai observé le bloc qui
évolue notamment lorsque le cortège
était parti d'opéra jusqu'à Bastille et
donc on était passé devant le Conseil
d'État et Ben et bah à ce moment là
évidemment les anarchistes signaient
tout au long de leur méfaits on les
connaît quand même bien sûr ceux qui
signe depuis longtemps et son fils
qu'est-ce qui se passe ils s'en fichiers
à se mes fichiers le renseignement
mais ça ne justifie pas une
interpellation néanmoins on aurait des
outils des outils légaux et notamment
celui de la vérification identité dès
lors que on sait parce qu'on a plusieurs
renseignements et des collègues de
renseignements qui connaissent bien leur
matière on pourrait évidemment en amont
suivre ces personnes et dès lors
qu'elles se regroupent en tout cas c'est
comme ça que ça se passait encore il y a
quelques années et jusqu'aux gilet jaune
c'est à dire se regrouper notamment à la
sortie des métros pour aller ensuite
exercer des violences et on a une
infraction qui est le fait de s'arrêter
en vue de commettre un délire on va
aujourd'hui
le faire et ils se forment au sein même
des manifestants et c'est plus difficile
en fait à caractériser la fraction
Thomas Rudigoz vous ça a beaucoup cassé
chez vous à Lyon qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en deux mots il y avait un black
bloc on va dire à peu près de 2000
personnes alors compartiment à Paris
c'est beaucoup moins mais c'est quand
même énorme pour une ville comme Lyon il
y avait deux blocs il y avait vraiment
des Black Blocs plus un millier d'autres
manifestants qu'on pourrait qualifier de
gilets jaunes extrémistes et plus de
différentes tendances et qui ont été
très vite très vite c'est ce que m'ont
dit les policiers qui ont été très
surpris c'est très vite ils ont ils ont
attaqué tout de suite ils ont été dans
la détérioration dans la violence dans
des actes quasi criminels puisque des
fois c'est des départs de feu de voiture
ça peut toucher aussi des pieds
d'immeubles et derrière ça peut aussi
les services de la sécurité civile les
pompiers n'interviennent pas rapidement
on peut imaginer le drame que cela
pourrait qu'on représente
et de grandes chaînes de commerce
Carrefour City un espresso des choses
comme ça on est bien au-delà de la
frontière stricte d'humilitant
radicalisé historique on va dire Black
Bloc on le voit bien tous les
témoignages des reportages Concorde
c'est au delà et il y a cette phrase qui
revient finalement il y a que la
violence qui marche ça doit vous
interpeller ça quand même quand vous
voyez que au fond elles sont pas
condamnées véritablement dans les
cortèges c'est violence bien sûr les
militants syndicalistes les condames
mais il y a beaucoup de gens qui des
approuvent pas qu'est-ce que vous dites
comment vous réagissez
par exemple que des élus de la
République ne puissent pas condamner et
puis il y a condamnation par exemple je
vois le maire de Lyon et ses adjoints
qui condamnent et dénoncent les
violences bon c'est bien c'est une
action mais qui ne nomme pas
les auteurs de ces faits que on en est
belle on en parle on avait parlé c'est
il vient de l'ultra gauche ils viennent
de mouvement anarchistes donc c'est
l'ultra gauche et parce que c'est
beaucoup plus large et parce qu'on a le
mot gauche on ne peut pas alors que
quand on doit dénoncer l'ultra droite et
moi je le fais souvent parce que à Lyon
on a des problématiques avec l'ultra
droite avec des gens comme génération
identitaires et d'autres on les nomme et
heureusement et bien moi je regrette que
quand des gens qui font de telle
violence mais qui viennent de mouvance
type anarchistes et ultra gauche on ne
puisse pas les nommer et c'est vrai que
par rapport à ce que disait Gérald
Darmanin je trouve les positions de
Monsieur Mélenchon très ambigu et
extrêmement
simple
il devrait vous me demandez pourquoi
ne donne pas ses violences c'est ce
qu'il dit je pense qu'il faut condamner
ces violences quel que soit les bords
politiques dont on est issu de la même
façon qu'à un moment donné il y avait
des mouvements d'ultra-droites pendant
les gilets jaunes qui ont mené des
exactions comme on est des violences et
il fallait les condamner et il faut les
arrêter il faut les démanteler et il
faut dissoudre ces mouvements d'extrême
droite de la même façon il faut
s'attaquer au mouvement d'ultra gauche
est-ce que
vous à la France insoumise vous les
condamnez clairement c'est violence bien
sûr et d'ailleurs je regrette que dans
le sujet de Stéphane blackowski et il
laisse entendre une sorte doute
là-dessus notamment je vous renvoie à
l'intervention d'Alexis Corbière
hier matin qui a parlé de dingue qui
était extrêmement clair moi je suis je
vous dire assez affligé et triste en
fait de l'état de mon pays parce que et
plus précisément de l'état de notre
démocratie aujourd'hui le Conseil
constitutionnel là tout à l'heure vous
l'avez dit a rendu une décision sur le
référendum d'initiative partagée est un
outil certains parfait mais qui est
censé donner la possibilité à des
citoyens de solliciter un référendum et
en l'occurrence c'était proposé pour la
loi des retraites bon le Conseil
constitutionnel a fermé cette porte ça
vient après le fait que le Conseil
constitutionnel est validé
sont vraiment fonder en droit sa
décision là la loi retraite ça vient
après le fait qu'elle nationale on n'est
pas pu voter parce qu'il y a eu un 49,3
ça vient après le fait que les syndicats
et organiser des manifestations mais
massives comme on les a pas vu depuis
des décennies en France des dizaines de
journées à des millions de manifestants
c'est cette absence de déboucher
politique à la contestation sur les
retraites qui fabrique la violence à
l'origine de la violence est-ce que vous
dites il faut il faut quand même
l'excuse ou pas bien sûr que non mais il
faut se départir de toute naïveté c'est
à dire que dans un le principe dans
notre constitution même c'est écrit
Verbatim article 2 Linéa 5 le principe
de notre République c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple c'est ce qui devrait tous
nous animer et quand vous avez 70% des
Français qui sont contre une loi
normalement dans un système qui
fonctionne bien cette loi ne devrait
même pas entrer à l'Assemblée nationale
donc et si en plus quand vous la
contestez de façon unitaire les 11
centrales syndicales toutes ensemble
ça ne marche pas vous faites grève ça ne
marche pas etc il y a rien qui marche
pas de chemin pour une modalité
pacifique de règlement du conflit vous
allez réagir comme avant je pense que
c'est faut que tout le monde prenne
conscience du fait que si nous voulons
la paix et moi je suis attachée à la
paix je suis attaché au fait que puisque
nous sommes nous les citoyens le
souverain quand nous avons l'impression
de concourir à l'expression la volonté
général et la loi va nous acceptons le
résultat des heures nous acceptant les
résultats des délibérales lever hier
pour applaudir les forces de l'ordre
lors des questions au gouvernement mais
bien sûr mais vraiment
pas réussi à le fêter avec ça c'est une
question
bon je dis ce que j'avais à dire sur le
le dysfonctionnement institutionnel je
pense qu'il trouvera sa solution dans un
passage à la Sixième République je pense
que le blocage il vient textuellement de
nos institutions qui donnent au
président le pouvoir d'abuser de son
pouvoir Thomas
après pour le reste sur ce qui est de
traitement on va dire maintien de
l'ordre le traitement policier est
judicieux du phénomène que vous avez
abordé bon je viens qu'on en parle mais
s'il y a bien une personne à qui il faut
pas confier l'enquête c'est Darmanin
puisqu'il a trouvé le responsable et
Mélenchon bon alors or vous avez bien vu
que c'est pas Mélenchon qui a qui a fait
quoi que ce soit oui mais Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dit la police tu est-ce que
vous trouvez
si vous voulez polémiquer c'est une
question soumise à l'occasion de ce qui
a eu il y a quand même des individus des
quand on est policier ou quand on est
journaliste c'est pas normal qu'on
subisse une atteinte à l'intégrité de
son corps juste parce qu'on est au
boulot ça n'est pas normal le policier
qui a été attaqué par ce cocktail
Molotov aujourd'hui là pendant qu'on
parle il est en souffrance les gens ont
eu peur pour lui ses collègues ont eu
peur pour lui-même il a eu peur pour sa
vie sa famille c'est pas pour que
derrière il y a de la politique Aillerie
politicienne moi je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ça je vous pose des questions parce
par rapport à tout ça et complet et pas
hémiplégique ce n'est pas normal que
juste parce qu'on manifeste une opinion
différente de celle de Monsieur Macron
on est aussi des atteintes à son
intégrité physique et aussi alors on va
essayer à célibataire on va essayer de
comprendre qu'on peut faire maintenant
mais c'est intéressant on est avec
Jérôme Durand c'est l'un de vos
collègues un élu sénateur socialiste en
visioconférence bonsoir monsieur vous
êtes sénateurs de Saône-et-Loire et vous
avez été observateur ce 1er mai au sein
de la brave on vous a vu d'ailleurs
casquer au milieu des policiers même des
gaz lacrymogènes qu'est-ce que vous avez
constaté lors de cette immersion
précisément j'ai constaté la violence
évidemment de violence de gens qui n'ont
pas grand chose à voir avec des
manifestants des syndicalistes des
militants politiques des militants
syndicaux les gens qui sont là pour
casser sans prendre au bien aux
personnes le travail que je fais moi
c'est un travail de parlementaire comme
font d'autres parlementaires autour de
votre table c'est un travail au long de
l'année c'était pas destiné d'ailleurs à
être rendu public et puis ça est devenu
parce que c'est
intéressant de voir un parlementaire
dans une manifestation enfin après 37
ans de manifestation du côté des
manifestants je trouve intéressant
d'aller voir comment le maintien de
l'ordre se produit en réalité comment il
organisé alors justement ce que vous en
avez tiré quelques enseignements
sur le maintien de l'ordre je sois très
immodeste et très malhonnête de dire en
ne voyant que un tout petit bout de la
réalité le bout de la rue un bout de
place des fumées des gaz des projectiles
du côté des forces de l'ordre en plus
d'avoir une vision objective de ce qui
s'est passé moi j'ai une vision
subjective de quelqu'un qui était avec
la brave à pied donc j'ai compris
qu'elles étaient les outils qu'ils
utilisaient quels étaient les circuits
de commandement qui étaient les leurs
les questions de formation déontologie
qui se posent derrière l'usage des
drones puisque c'était le sujet du jour
voilà donc c'est des indicateurs pour un
travail de parlementaire de fond en
termes de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement ou en termes de
d'amendement législatif de production
législative ce que j'ai vu effectivement
parce que on le ressent dans la danse
herb moi heureusement non mais mes
voisins l'ont reçu puisqu'il y a des
blessés qui qui se trouvaient parmi les
forces de l'ordre juste à côté de moi
c'est un exercice qui est extrêmement
difficile ce que je retiens aussi pour
terminer c'est que il y a une violence
structurelle et les forces de l'ordre le
maintien de l'ordre ce sont des
fonctionnaires de police qui ou de
gendarmes qui sont là pour encaisser les
coûts tenir les manifestants mais ça a
un coût c'est un coup humain c'est un
coup professionnel et je suis pas
certain quand même qu'on soit très très
performant en la matière vis-à-vis de
nos voisins européens puisque à la fin
d'une journée comme le 1er mai il y a
des blessés tous les côtés beaucoup il y
a beaucoup de confusions donc il y a
sans doute un travail à remettre un
ouvrage à remettre sur le métier parce
que on peut progresser on y va sur les
solutions est-ce qu'il faut une loi
nouvelle anti-casseurs comment endiguer
le phénomène est-ce qu'il faut toucher à
la loi ou tout simplement changer la
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre je vous
passe la parole dans un tout petit
instant mais d'abord les explications
d'Hélène Bonduelle
ce sont ces casseurs c'est blackbloc que
le ministre de l'Intérieur voudrait
interdire dans les manifestations et
j'espère que j'aurai les moyens
techniques de pouvoir continuer à
combattre cette violence et qui aura
évidemment des sanctions judiciaires
extrêmement fortes Gérald Darmanin
réclame surtout une nouvelle loi
anti-casseurs en tous les cas on y
réfléchit
et je rencontre vendredi le ministre de
l'intérieur on va travailler ensemble et
bien sûr il faut une vraie fermeté alors
qu'elle pourrait être ce nouvel arsenal
législatif contre les casseurs depuis
2019 et les démonstrations de force des
gilets jaunes la loi a renforcé le
maintien de l'ordre les policiers et
gendarmes peuvent inspecter les
véhicules les fouiller les bagages aux
abords des manifestations un nouveau
délit interdit également de se
dissimuler volontairement le visage sans
motif légitime la loi prévoyait aussi
que les préfets puissent interdire de
manifestations toute personne présentant
une menace particulière pour l'ordre
public une disposition sur le même
modèle que les interdictions
administratives des supporters violents
dans les stades de foot
mais l'article a été retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel car selon lui il
portait tout droit d'expression
collective des idées et des opinions une
atteinte qui n'est pas adaptée pas
nécessaire et pas proportionné des
mesures qui auraient porté atteinte à la
liberté de manifester
on a compris qu'on ne peut pas et c'est
bien compréhensible arrêtez des gens
sans flagrant délit avant même de façon
préventive qu'une infraction soit
commise et c'est pour ça que le texte a
été retoqué qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez il faut passer par la loi ou
au contraire il faut faire autrement sur
le terrain avec les forces de l'ordre
avant de répondre j'aimerais juste faire
une réflexion ce que je la phrase sous
les yeux depuis tout à l'heure prêt à
casser du flic moi je suis assez mal à
l'aise avec cette phrase je disais
encore il y a quelques jours à vos
d'autres journalistes je le dis
particulièrement parce qu'on est sur la
Chaîne Parlementaire donc c'est une
chaîne quand même assez équilibrée je
pense qu'on casse de la vaisselle mais
on blesse et on tue des humains rien que
prêt à casser du flic je pense que ça
déshumanise aussi les policiers c'est
tout comme l'expression qui a été faite
dans un des reportage que vous avez
diffusé les affrontements entre les
policiers et le black bloc en fait comme
si c'était deux gangs qui se donnaient
rendez-vous pour régler leur compte
entre deux quartiers et comme si entre
les deux il y avait plus rien il y avait
plus de société plus d'institutions
notamment de justice origan comme s'il y
avait plus finalement
3 comme s'il y avait plus le peuple en
société voilà et c'est assez dramatique
parce qu'au final ça devient une affaire
entre les membres du Black Bloc alors
justement remettons et les forces de le
citoyen le commun la société pour sortir
du face-à-face et merci de cette mise au
point qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors
je pense que oui en effet et pourtant je
suis très attaché aux libertés
individuel qu'il faut légiférer de
manière à faire que non pas on n'empêche
pas les manifestants d'accéder aux
manifestations je suis très attaché à ce
que les préfets n'aient pas des
prérogatifs sans contrôle je ne voudrais
pas qu'une autorité administrative
puisse très librement prendre des
décisions sans aucun contrôle et
d'ailleurs je pense que le débat si on
l'a aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il y a un
échec aussi de l'autorité judiciaire qui
n'a pas les moyens peut-être de mener
jusqu'à au bout des démarches en tout
cas des décisions qui empêcheraient ces
gens-là de revenir toutes les semaines
concrètement on dit tous les toutes les
semaines on a 500 milles 2000 personnes
ils sont toujours les 500 000 même ce
sont des personnes qui ne sont pas
neutralisées par les institutions et qui
reviennent incessamment toutes les
semaines ce sont les mêmes quasiment les
mêmes profils qui reviennent et
notamment je parle le pari intra-muros
on a des groupuscules qui sont là
expliquez-nous parce que on a réussi à
interdire de stade par des sanctions
pénales d'individus arrêtés les
hooligans pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
faire la même chose avec les Black Blocs
parce que c'est plus facile de
caractériser une infraction dans un
stade ou à son abord parce qu'on a des
caméras on a des moyens en fait de
pouvoir localiser et de caractériser les
infractions que dans une manifestation
ou et je l'ai vu de mes propres yeux on
a des jets de projectiles de toutes
parts de la fumée c'est beaucoup de
confusion comme c'est le mot qui a été
utilisé et donc même s'il y a un
témoignage des policiers qui vont
désigner des individus et bien les
magistrats vont dire oui mais
l'infraction n'est pas suffisamment
caractérisée donc on libère et à partir
du moment où ce sont des personnes qui
sont libérées quand bien même on a des
soupçons très très plausibles et formes
de dire que cette personne a commis et
bien on a du mal derrière en tout cas
l'autorité judiciaire a imposé une
interdiction donc vous voulez quand même
une loi c'est quand même possible
trouver un chemin qui soit
constitutionnel au moment où on a une
redondance des profils et des individus
qui chaque fois sont interpellés dans un
contexte particulier on l'a fait
notamment pour les guetteurs en matière
de trafic de stupéfiant vous savez un en
matière de trafic de suppléant est très
difficile en fait à poursuivre
pénalement parce qu'il est juste assis
sur une chaise il crie à l'arrivée des
policiers et finalement n'a pas grand
chose à lui reprocher et il a fallu que
progressivement les parquets s'adaptent
et au bout de 5 10 15 20 interpellations
de la même personne assise sur la chaise
qui crie on puisse supposer qu'il
participe au trafic de stupéfiant et
bien on peut aussi supposer que 15 20
fois la même personne interpellée
vous ne pouvez plus interdiction juste
une dernière chose une nouvelle fois ce
ne soit pas des manifestants ce sont des
personnes qui viennent casser qui
viennent par la Révolution la terreur et
la violence imposer leur idéologie moi
j'ai pas d'autres mots que le terrorisme
je suis désolé le mot peut paraître fort
et je pense pas que ce soit un nuancier
sur le visage qui définit si oui ou non
vous êtes un terroriste non c'est l'acte
que vous commettez et quand vous faites
passer vos idées par la violence c'est
du terrorisme donc ces personnes en sont
sauf que c'est très difficile de
caractériser parce que c'est bien de
monsieur et madame tout le monde je l'ai
vu de mes propres yeux en effet des gens
très lambda qui rentrent chez eux et qui
sont favorisés intellectuellement
Thierry Vincent les solutions
sur le terme terrorisme parce que je
trouve que c'est quand même
problématique d'appeler d'un même terme
les blagues blocs quel que soit les
exactions qui commettent que le même
terme désigne ça et l'État islamique qui
fait 130 morts au bataclanique et
pourtant
de guerre qui brûle et qui tue dans
l'intention de faire passer vos idées
politiques vous allez trouver qualifier
quel groupe de terrorisme le débat c'est
quelle solution chacun il faudra son
appréciation sur le mot terroriste que
c'est que la violence
aveugles
sur au fond légiférer en disant voilà il
y a une réitération de de fait de profil
on peut interdire alors d'abord on fait
alors depuis hier j'entends
effectivement la comparaison avec les
William ça a été fait ça régule une
partie du on trouve une grosse partie du
problème du lilianisme je trouve c'est
pas tout à fait le même nature parce que
si vous voulez aller regarder un match
de foot ça fait pas partie des
constitutionnel garantie par une
démocratie la liberté de manifester pour
moi et un peu plus sacré que la liberté
d'avoir un match de foot donc c'est un
peu différent pour moi c'est un peu
comme si retirer le droit de vote à
quelqu'un je sais pas si vous le faire
ou pas mais c'est à réfléchir parce que
je trouve que la comparaison est un peu
est un peu inable
de même le guetteur dans un alors c'est
peut-être pas vous quand vous avez
comparé par exemple le trafic c'est pas
la même chose parce que c'est là là vous
avez une bande avec des des contours
sont relativement définis les autres
pays ont été tués alors qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont fait ailleurs en Allemagne par
exemple au départ en Allemagne il y a
disons que là le maintien de l'ordre est
très différent ils vont plus encore à
corps il y a il y a moins d'armes
susceptibles en revanche il y a une il y
a une des fonctions pénales qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement sévères mais il
y a eu aussi
un bloc est-ce que vous pensez qu'il est
utile là de trouver une majorité dans
l'hémicycle pour y parvenir premièrement
je pense que quelqu'un qui prépare un
cocktail Molotov qui le met dans son sac
et qui va une manif déjà il tombe sous
le coup de la loi et si un renseignement
qui peut l'identifier je comprends pas
qu'il arrive à accéder à la
manifestation donc il y a pas besoin
d'une nouvelle loi pour ça mais très
souvent la deuxième les armes sont
cachées la deuxième chose la deuxième
chose c'est que
il faut que aussi que les syndicats
policiers à mon avis madame vous preniez
peut-être conscience ou peut-être que
vous l'avez déjà je crois que vous avez
déjà des idées des choses dans cette
dans ce sens que comme pendant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes
le gouvernement se défaut sur vous pour
traiter le mouvement social j'ai été la
première et peut-être la seule à dire
que l'on envoie les policiers régler des
problèmes économiques et sociaux de
exactement donc les corps intermédiaires
ont été démontrés le dialogue social
n'existe plus donc
dans la rue pour contester les 64 ans la
difficulté c'est que la criminalité
d'une façon générale c'est complexe à
traiter la criminalité on va dire
prétendument politique c'est pas
forcément nouveau dans l'histoire de du
monde mais on y est et c'est pas non
plus simple à gérer mais pour ce qui est
du volet politique de ce que dire c'est
à dire ce que nous ce qui nous concerne
l'oie
on va essayer de trouver un chemin notre
rôle politique à nous c'est pas de se
défausser sur la question du maintien de
l'ordre ou de la judiciarisation
politique par exemple ce sera le 8 juin
de voter la loi qui abroge la loi
retraite voilà parce que ça c'est
démocratique c'est magnifique la fin des
64 ans
le raisonnement des insoumis
parfaitement clair vous aurez le mot de
la fin pour Renaissance
avec madame je serai assez favorable à
une évolution de la loi par contre il
faut qu'on trouve le moyen moi je suis
pour une interdiction administrative
malheureusement ça a été retoqué censuré
par le Conseil constitutionnel donc là
il faut paré à ce risque là faut voir
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire évoluer pour
justement anticiper pour ces individus
qui ont déjà sont déjà passés dans les
mains de la police ou de la justice et
bien que cette fois-ci ne puisse pas
revenir une manifestation on sait très
bien qu'ils vont mener des violences
donc c'est c'est là qu'il faut qu'on
trouve le moyen de parer à ces individus
qui reviennent régulièrement et qui s'en
sortent pour la plupart du temps assez
confortablement même s'il y a eu à Lyon
dès condamnations mais il faut qu'il y
en ait plus et peut-être qu'il faut
aussi graduer en augmentant l'échelle
des peines merci on va s'arrêter là
voilà quelques pistes de solution sur la
merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous
restez avec moi Pauline Hadès Mevel dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties prit
de nos affranchis ce soir ffteel de
libération on va nous parler de la 69 le
projet d'autoroute ultra contesté comme
celui de sainte-solide mais loin d'être
enterré Isabelle Lasserre va nous
éclairer sur la contre-offensive
ukrainienne sur le point de démarrer et
puis elles a mon dingava dans Bourbon
Express exit le rip RIP le rip vous ne
direz pourquoi tout à l'heure à tout de
suite mais d'abord on va se plonger dans
le classement mondial de Reporters sans
frontières un panorama je le disais
qu'il fait froid dans le dos en cette
Journée mondiale de la presse de la
liberté de la presse regardez c'est dans
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle
si on vous invite Pauline Hadès Mevel
c'est parce que vous êtes porte parole
de Reporters sans frontières comme
chaque année depuis 1985 votre ONG
publie un état des lieux des libertés de
la presse dans le monde cette année
encore votre constat est alarmant les
conditions d'exercices du journalisme ne
sont bonnes que dans trois pays sur 10
comme la Norvège l'Irlande ou encore le
Danemark en tête du classement la France
elle gagne deux places mais finit
seulement 24e dans cette pays sur 10
dans le monde les journalistes ne
peuvent donc pas travailler librement
tout en bas du classement trois pays
asiatiques la Corée du Nord la Chine ou
encore le Vietnam
cette année c'est dans un pays en
particulier que se déroule la bataille
pour l'information l'Ukraine avec
reportage sans frontières vous déposez 7
plaintes auprès de la Cour pénale
internationale pour des crimes de guerre
visant une centaine de journalistes vous
dénoncez la propagande du Kremlin qui ne
laisse d'autres choix au reporter que de
propager de fausses informations ce
qu'avait refusé de faire Marina ofcia
nicova cette journaliste a osé s'opposer
en direct à la télévision russe
aujourd'hui elle est réfugiée en France
sous protection policière nos créances
cette réalité parallèle nous avons
déshumanisé les Ukrainiens nous parlions
pas de comme des personnes mais comme
des nazis plus largement vous constatez
le développement des fake news d'autant
plus efficace qu'elles s'appuie sur
l'intelligence artificielle les
capacités de manipulation inédites dans
l'histoire de l'humanité estompe les
différences entre le vrai et le faux le
réel et l'artificiel l'effet les
artefacts mettant en péril le
journalisme et plus largement le 3
l'information pour tous aujourd'hui nous
avons envie de vous poser une question
vous dressez un tableau sombre de la
liberté de la presse mais est-ce
vraiment pire qu'avant
alors réponse alors est-ce que c'est
pire qu'avant en tout cas la liberté de
la presse n'est pas bonne c'est les
chiffres le 10 et désolant mais c'est
vrai quand on regarde aujourd'hui que
seulement trois citoyens sur 10
exercent en tout cas trois journalistes
sur 10 dans le monde exercent dans des
conditions favorables c'est largement
insuffisant ça s'est dégradé ça c'est
dégradé en Europe c'est ça ça s'est
dégradé dans les démocraties et ça c'est
dégradé pour toutes les raisons qu'on
évoque dans le classement de la liberté
de la presse qu'on publie aujourd'hui on
commence par les champions c'est
toujours les pays du Nord et c'est
encore une fois la Norvège sur le podium
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont plus que nous dans
le respect du pluralisme et de
l'indépendance de la presse pays là
alors ils ont effectivement le mot
respect c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un
respect des journalistes il y a un
respect des règles il y a un pluralisme
très large notamment en Norvège qui est
donc le premier pays du classement
depuis cette année mais la Finlande est
souvent dans le trio de tête la Suède
également
les Pays-Bas maintenant entre reviennent
un petit peu dans la danse puisque ils
reviennent 6ème aussi et puis l'Irlande
et deuxième sont des pays dans la
majorité qui sont très respectueux du
travail des journalistes c'est-à-dire
qu'il y aura pas d'ingérence politique
en tout cas quand il y en a eu en
Finlande le Premier ministre a vu tout
de suite sa carrière vaciller il a eu
beaucoup de problèmes donc ce genre de
choses ne se passe pas dans ces pays-là
la France 24e peut beaucoup mieux faire
non elle est passée parfaite que celle
la liberté la presse chez nous alors
elle est pas si parfaite que ça et je
crois que en fait il suffit de regarder
sur le terrain et de voir notamment en
ce moment tout ce qui se passe dans les
manifestations avec les journalistes
blessés qui couvrent les manifestations
contre les retraites pour voir qu'il y a
quand même un problème c'est difficile
de documenter d'informer dans les
manifestations c'est difficile de rendre
compte de certaines réalités en France
aujourd'hui quand on est journaliste
c'est difficile aussi d'enquêter pour
diverses raisons on voit quand même que
les se concentre dans les mains de
businessman de
d'industriel en fait qui
rachèterachèterachète et puis qui
finalement licencie licencié qui font
des plans alors évidemment à l'échelle
de la population mondiale les conditions
d'exercice de ce très beau métier qui
est le nôtre sont absolument
catastrophiques plus de 50 % de la
population mondiale vit dans un pays où
la situation est très grave ce sont
évidemment les dictatures les régimes
autoritaires la Chine l'Iran la Russie
beaucoup de pays en Afrique l'Iran par
exemple il y a plus un seul journaliste
étranger qui peut couvrir la révolution
en Iran sinon c'est la prison c'est très
très très difficile aujourd'hui il y a
24 journalistes derrière les barreaux il
y en avait 14 avant le début des
manifestations le 16 septembre il y en a
eu jusqu'à 37 beaucoup de femmes elles
sont elles ont d'ailleurs été
honoré hier par l'UNESCO parce qu'elles
sont ultra courageuses dans c'est
extrêmement difficile
les représailles et puis les pressions
l'emprisonnement des mesures arbitraires
qui font que documenter ce qui se passe
les manifestations sans parler des
coupures internet parce qu'évidemment
c'est la mesure suprême c'est à dire
qu'il y a plus d'informations qui sort
et la série la Russie évidemment franchi
un grand supplémentaire dans sa guerre
de propagande depuis l'invasion de
l'Ukraine il y a une chape de plomb qui
s'est abattue surtout les médias
indépendants à Moscou il y en avait déjà
très très peu RSF on l'a vu à participer
à l'extfiltration de Marina
opposant au régime qui a eu le courage
de montrer cette pancarte pour les
Ukrainiens comment va-t-elle comment
vit-elle cette situation en dehors de
son pays est-ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle a
peur alors Marina vous aime Kova est en
France aujourd'hui elle a effectivement
quitté son pays elle a bravé les
interdits et le reporters Sans
Frontières l'accompagner dans son voyage
depuis la Russie aujourd'hui elle
continue de dénoncer la situation sur
place et elle n'est pas la seule et puis
elle essaye de porter la parole de en
tout cas d'une certaine catégorie de
russe qui s'oppose à ce que fait le
président Poutine sur place mais la
Russie c'est aussi c'est dramatique il y
a même un journaliste américain qui a
été arrêté absolument il y a un
journaliste qui a été donc
absolument et puis donc ça c'est
vraiment un mauvais souvenir de la
guerre froide les rédactions sont
complètement
désertés c'est extrêmement difficile de
travailler et puis toutes ces mesures en
fait qui sont appliquées sont des
mesures de d'intimidation au fond c'est
une façon de dire nous vous y risquez
pas vous allez subir la même chose
comment on peut imaginer qu'un autre
journaliste américain pourrait ou un
journaliste russophone américain
installé puisse continuer de documenter
essayer de d'enquêter en sachant que son
confrère est emprisonné
visionnage ce qui empêche évidemment la
guerre froide les ennemis de la liberté
de la presse alors évidemment on les
connaît on en a parlé ce sont les
dictatures les états mafieux corrompus
les politiciens avéreux mais ce qui est
très intéressant dans dans ce classement
dans ce rapport des RECF c'est cette
écosystème dont vous parlez qui favorise
la désinformation la propagande c'est ce
que vous appelez l'industrie du
simulacre tout à fait c'est vrai qu'on
connaissait les opposants les ennemis du
journalisme classique c'est-à-dire
effectivement des opposants politiques
des pouvoirs politiques des États
autoritaires mais là c'est greffé dessus
des acteurs de la désinformation
c'est-à-dire des acteurs qui n'ont pas
soucis de protéger l'information qui
sont prêts à la marchander et donc on
dénonçait souvent le fait que les
plateformes ne protégaient pas assez la
fiabilité de l'information mais avec
cette propagande qui s'est répandue
notamment cette année qui est
extrêmement virulente on voit que
finalement les réseaux sociaux de
manière générale laisse
se répandre des de la désinformation
l'alimentante on va parler de midjornet
et de ses intelligences artificielles
qui fabriquent des images saisissantes
qui se deviennent virales on en voit une
avec Emmanuel Macron mais puisque vous
parlez des plateformes Elon Musk c'est
un ennemi de la liberté de la presse
aujourd'hui le patron Twitter vous le
diriez aujourd'hui Elon Musk c'est
quelqu'un qui finalement censure des
informations c'est quelqu'un qui fait
fit de certaines règles déontologiques
et donc qui ne défend pas le journaliste
il a effectivement les choses ont changé
sur Twitter donc on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas se fier aux bonnes intentions
en tout cas qu'il s'est prêté en rage
ton Twitter et pour défendre la liberté
de l'information pas du tout comment le
journalisme plus largement va continuer
à exister
quand le vrai du Faune n'arrive plus à
être détectable on a vu cette image
d'intelligence artificielle je vais vous
ai montré une autre c'est une une vidéo
regardez la vidéo d'une présentatrice au
Koweït regardez un info de bas
elle est complètement fabriquée par
l'intelligence artificielle on est au
Koweït alors là c'est la porte ouverte à
toutes les désinformations si on peut
fabriquer des journaux télévisés
entièrement fait de propagande comment
résister alors fabriquer une
présentatrice au fond est-ce que c'est
plus grave que de fabriquer de la
désinformation à grande échelle comme
certains états le font on parlait des
ennemis des États qui sont ennemis de la
liberté de la presse on sait que la
Chine est une grande fabricante de
désinformations de propagande et
pourvoyeuses mais aussi exportatrice la
Russie c'est pareil je crois que c'était
le plus important c'est de voir surtout
que ces états exportent leur propagande
notamment la Russie par exemple elle ne
se contente pas des zones occupées en
Ukraine pour inonder sa désinformation
et sa propagande pro et pour faire du
bourrage de crâne non ça se passe en
Afrique ça se passe au Mali ça se passe
au Burkina Faso ou les milices Wagner
qui jusqu'ici étaient un petit peu plus
discrète répandait cette propagande pro
russe au Mali
au Burkina et qui aujourd'hui finalement
même réussi à faire que la jante au
pouvoir
soutien officiellement en tout cas
géopolitiques très très clairs d'un mot
le journalisme a encore un avenir quand
on voit l'intelligence artificielle qui
remplace avec tchétype la presse écrite
tous ces présentatrices à la télé
entièrement robots entièrement
intelligence artificielle oui j'ai envie
de dire grâce à des organisations qui
combattent et qui font libérer des
journalistes et on y arrive assez
régulièrement ce sont nos grandes
victoires oui on a tout intérêt à
continuer à faire du journalisme et à se
battre pour le défendre et merci d'être
là reporter sans frontières et vive la
démocratie il va falloir trouver un peu
les moyens de s'armer face à tous ces
défis vous restez avec moi Pauline c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis pour
leur parti pris vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite bienvenue
fftel de libération qui nous parle ce
soir de la 69 le nouveau sens solide on
pouvait penser qu'il serait enterré ce
projet d'autoroute et ben pas forcément
Isabelle la servançoire bonsoir du
Figaro bien sûr on va parler de
l'Ukraine mais dans comme chaque soir on
va commencer par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée ce soir par Elsa mon
bingava exit le rip Elsa et oui ce soir
Myriam je vous raconte l'histoire perdu
une nouvelle déception pour les
opposants à la réforme des retraites qui
cependant ne baisse pas les bras cette
décision vous l'avez dit c'était celle
sur le rip le référendum d'initiative
partagée rendu à 19h par le Conseil
constitutionnel un conseil sous haute
surveillance en très forte présence
policière aux abords du Conseil
constitutionnel il en était de même aux
abords de l'Assemblée nationale tout à
l'heure alors le RIB vous vous en
souvenez peut-être
c'est pour demander un référendum la
gauche en a proposé deux le premier a
été retoqué en même temps que la réforme
l était globalement validée par le
Conseil constitutionnel et donc le
deuxième verdict toujours à 19h et pour
les sages les mêmes causes produisent
les mêmes effets regardez à la date
d'enregistrement de la saisine
l'interdiction de fixer l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite n'emporte pas de
changement dans l'État de droit un peu
plus loin puisque la gauche avait mis
une mesure financière et bien celle-ci
ne fait que augmenter un budget ce n'est
donc pas une réforme sociale pour les
sages et donc il n'y aura pas de RIP sur
le sujet la nups a réagi très vite
évidemment aux quatre colonnes à 19h
tapante on était présent c'est pas
vraiment une surprise pour eux
évidemment mais surtout le message
qu'ils ont voulu faire passer c'est que
le combat ne s'arrête pas là écoutez
je traduis chaque groupe d'oppositions
dispose d'une journée par session pour
proposer différentes textes le groupe
yote c'est un petit groupe composé de
centrises de députés ultramarins des
socialistes en rupture avec la nupette
alors au début le gouvernement voyait
d'un bon œil ce groupe et bien ce groupe
s'est transformé en un fer de lance
contre la réforme c'est eux qui ont
défendu notamment la motion de censure
pour faire tomber Elisabeth borne et
donc le 8 juin ils vont déposer une
proposition de loi pour abroger la
réforme des retraites on va ressortir
les calculettes une chance de passer
d'être votée ou pas bah écoutez en tout
cas pour la première des réformes des
retraites le gouvernement a dû utiliser
le 49-3 n'étant pas sûr d'avoir une
majorité peut-être donc que ça peut
passer le parcours et cependant
compliqué faut que ce soit repris au
Sénat puis retour à l'Assemblée on en a
donc pas fini mais de toute façon vous
l'avez entendu pour la nupaisse
notamment le combat ne s'arrêtera
quasiment jamais et vous le suivez ça
comme le laisse sur le sommaire merci
beaucoup Elsa mondingava Isabelle
Lasserre la contre-offensive ukrainienne
se prépare et voilà que Moscou accuse
les Ukrainiens d'avoir essayé
d'assassiner Vladimir Poutine à l'aide
de deux drones qui ont attaqué le
Kremlin ça y est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est le début de l'offensive non pas
encore mais cette initiative cette
attaque et en fait indirectement lié à
la construction
ukrainienne alors tout le monde se
demande qui est derrière cette
spectaculaire attaque alors ça peut être
les Ukrainiens qui pourraient vouloir
déstabiliser le pouvoir politique russe
avant de lancer leur contre-offensive
sauf que vos lot-démir Zelenski ce soir
à dit qu'il n'avait absolument rien à
voir avec l'attaque il a dit on
n'attaque pas Vladimir Poutine on le
laisse au tribunal ça peut être
l'opposition russe et ensuite ça peut
être Vladimir Poutine lui-même le
Kremlin lui-même qui pourrait justifier
ainsi une une riposte identique contre
le président ukrainien d'ailleurs
l'ancien président Mitri medve ce soir
c'est empressé d'appeler à l'élimination
physique de volodies Zelenski et bon
alors la véritable offensive elle aura
lieu
alors elle aura lieu sans doute au cours
du mois de mai la boue a séché d'abord
donc les routes sont praticables et la
plupart des équipements militaires qui
ont été fournis par les qui ont été
promis par les Occidentaux sont arrivés
sur place alors tout le monde s'y prend
pas d'abord les Ukrainiens ils ont formé
des nouvelles brigades d'assaut ils
mettent la mien au dernier préparatif
nous sommes prêts à affirmer hier le
ministre de la Défense et depuis
plusieurs jours l'Ukraine multiplie les
actes de sabotage à la fois sur le sol
russe et en Crimée pour affaiblir les
systèmes d'appui de l'armée russe et
pour déstabiliser les militaires russes
avant l'offensif les Russes ensuite ils
ont construit des fortifications sur les
lignes de front ils ont transformé la
Crimée en un véritable camp retranché et
ils ont annulé les cérémonies du 9 mai
qui célèbre la victoire de l'URSS contre
l'Allemagne Asie dans plusieurs régions
et nous les occidentaux les occidentaux
on se prépare aussi on prépare déjà avec
les Ukrainiens main dans la main cette
offensive la position des Européens
désormais l'objet d'un consensus il
s'agit de tout faire pour que les
Ukrainiens gagnent la guerre et
d'ailleurs Paris s'apprête à livrer dans
trois semaines de nouvelles armes et de
nouvelles munitions à Kiev mais alors il
y a une série de grands rendez-vous
internationaux qui se profile là dans
les deux mois qui viennent il y a Alger
7 il y a le sommet de l'OTAN il y a un
prochain Conseil européen et au tout au
sein de ces conseils de ces grands
rendez-vous internationaux le sort de
l'Ukraine et aussi son avenir en fait au
sein de l'Union européenne
seront vraiment discutés c'est là qu'on
voit que le consensus européen n'est
plus aussi fort que ça parce que
personne enfin en tout cas il y a
plusieurs en fait définition de ce que
devrait être une paix en Ukraine selon
qu'on se situe à la frontière de la
Russie où au sud de l'Europe alors à
Paris on considère que le conflit se
terminera forcément autour d'une table
de négociation peut-être même avec
Vladimir Poutine et qu'il faut tout
faire pour les Ukrainiens de force pour
aborder cette nouvelle étape avoirsovie
et à Vilnius on considère au contraire
que la victoire de l'Ukraine comme la
défaite de la Russie doivent être totale
pour que la sécurité puisse être revenue
dans la région ça veut dire que ça elle
doit donc la victoire doit aller jusqu'à
la le départ de Vladimir Poutine et la
récupération de la Crimée on a un
scénario préféré non entre nous allez
merci beaucoup c'était limpide je
signale cher Isabelle que Macron Poutine
des liaisons dangereuses est en
librairie aux éditions l'Observatoire et
qu'on aura le plaisir d'en parler dans
le détail toutes les deux demain puisque
vous serez dans le fauteuil du grand
témoin on se dépêche Eve vous allez nous
parler ce soir du projet d'autoroute de
l'a69 c'est la nouvelle cible des
soulèvements de la terre cette
association écologiste très présente à
Sainte Soline pour contester les méga
bassines après la grande manifestation
qui a rassemblé des milliers de
personnes c'était le 22 avril dernier
est-ce qu'il est enterré ce projet
d'autoroute on aurait pu penser mais au
contraire le ministre des Transports
Clement Beaune a annoncé hier lors des
questions à l'assemblée que les travaux
avaient commencé la 69 donc il doit
relier Castres à Toulouse à peu près sur
une cinquantaine de kilomètres devrait
donc voir le jour en 2025 on l'écoute
Clément bonne voilà je veux souligner
justement son état d'avancement il a
fait l'objet d'engagement contractuel il
a fait l'objet de recours puisque nous
sommes leurs états de droit et tous ont
été déboutés par la justice les travaux
de ce projet ont commencé ça n'est donc
plus tout à fait un projet mais un début
de réalisation donc il aura lieu ce
projet d'autoroute le ministre des
Transports a changé d'avis en tout cas
il s'était montré plus hésitant le 22
avril enfin après la grande
manifestation il avait assuré que la 69
allait faire partie des de la grande
remise à plat des projets autoroutes
autoroutiers qu'a lancé le gouvernement
pourquoi vous cet été on peut penser que
le gouvernement depuis les violences à
sainte-solines contre les magabastines
craint que la force ne l'emporte sur le
droit sachant que il est quand même le
premier responsable de cette croyance
selon laquelle la violence paie
rappelez-vous Notre-Dame-des-Landes
pendant de la campagne de 2017 Emmanuel
Macron avait dit c'était engagé à
respecter le résultat du référendum qui
avait vu le oui quand même l'emporter à
55 % et en 2018 coup de tonnerre Édouard
Philippe annonce que le projet est
enterré certains à l'époque comme la
mère socialiste de Nantes Johanna Roland
dénonce un véritable déni de démocratie
qui affaiblit l'État de droit alors
c'est un peu comme la réforme des
retraites si je comprends bien il faut
pas que la rue gagne faut pas accéder à
la rue c'est ça pas céder à la foule oui
d'autant que le projet il est défendu
par la majorité des élus de la région
Occitanie de droite comme de gauche du
président PS de la du conseil
départemental du Tarn à la patronne de
la région Carole Delga en passant par le
député Renaissance les sanitaires les
sénateurs sont tristes etc et pour eux
cette autoroute est indispensable parce
qu'il faut rattraper le retard de la
région en termes d'équipement de grands
équipements il faut permettre l'essor de
l'économie et puis aussi et je le disent
il faut assurer un futur meilleur à nos
enfants et ils ont
ils ont ils ont lancé une mise en garde
très claire dans le Figaro au
gouvernement leur disant notre
département ne peut pas devenir l'otage
d'activistes qui remettent en cause tout
le parcours légal et démocratique
réalisé autour de ce projet soit 20 ans
de dialogues d'échanges et de travail et
donc il y a pas un mot sur les risques
écologiques les procès faits sur
l'environnement non ils ont parlé que
d'économie de retard de développement
etc alors que c'est vrai que ce sont
quand même 343 hectares précisément de
terres agricoles et naturelle qui vont
être artificialisés un territoire qui va
être coupé en deux alors certes le
concessionnaire
atosca a prévu des compensations
environnementales et c'est important
c'est 25% à peu près du coût du projet
on va replanter des arbres on va recréer
des zones humides on va renaturer des
carrières etc on au début des ouvrages
pour permettre la circulation de la
faune autour de l'autoroute voilà mais
alors d'un mot nous reste deux secondes
on va réduire on la construit ou pas
cette autoroute selon vous bah oui moi
je dirais si puisque il faut un parti
pris oui au nom de la démocratie du
respect des engagements pris et de
l'État de droit merci on n'est pas fini
vous l'avez compris le temps nous était
compté ce soir merci les affranchis
mesdames et Merci à VOUS
Pauline alas Mevel merci pour le travail
des RECF continuez on a besoin de vous
c'est la fin de cette émission très
belle soirée documentaire qui commence
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain
[Musique]